ยินดีต้อนรับกลับสู่ Quantum Computing in Practice ฉัน Olivia Lanes เป็นเจ้าภาพ ครั้งที่แล้วเราดูตัวอย่างของ
approach Quantum Computing สำหรับปัญหา optimization ที่รู้จักว่า Max Cut โดยใช้ QUBO formulation เรา
ไปลึกมาก แต่นั่นเป็นแค่ตัวอย่างหนึ่งของ approach หนึ่ง วันนี้เราจะพูดถึง near-term application
ในวงกว้างขึ้นและพัฒนา intuition ของเราสำหรับปัญหาประเภทต่าง ๆ ที่เราคาดว่าจะหา quantum solution ที่มีประโยชน์
สำหรับและดูตัวอย่างล่าสุดของงานสำคัญที่ทำในชุมชนของเราที่ระดับ utility
scale ก่อนหน้าเราพูดถึงสั้น ๆ ว่าไม่ใช่ทุกปัญหาต้องการพลังงานการคำนวณเพิ่มเติม
โดยเฉพาะ Quantum Computing เพื่อแก้อย่างมีประสิทธิภาพ สิ่งเหล่านี้คือปัญหาที่คุณคุ้นเคยมากที่สุด
เช่น เลขคณิต การ scroll social media บางทีเล่น Tetris, Doom หรือเกมวิดีโออื่น เราถือว่า
สิ่งเหล่านี้เป็นปัญหาง่าย ในทางตรงกันข้าม มีปัญหาที่ยากมาก ๆ เช่น การหา prime factor ของ
integer ขนาดใหญ่ ซึ่งเป็นพื้นฐานของการเข้ารหัส RSA และสิ่งที่ Shor's algorithm ออกแบบมาแก้ อีก
ตัวอย่างคือการหา solution ใน unsorted data set สิ่งนี้สามารถแก้ได้ทางทฤษฎีโดย quantum algorithm ที่รู้จักว่า
Grover's algorithm อย่างไรก็ตาม ผู้เชี่ยวชาญส่วนใหญ่เห็นด้วยว่า algorithm ประเภทนี้จะต้องการ
การ implement error correction และเรายังไม่ถึงตรงนั้นทางเทคโนโลยี ดังนั้นขณะเราก้าวหน้าใน
บทเรียนนี้และในการเดินทางการเรียนรู้ควอนตัมของคุณ จำไว้ว่าเรากำลังมองหา Sweet Spot ตรงกลางที่นี่
มันเป็นปัญหาที่ยากที่จะแก้ไข แต่นั่นก็คือสิ่งที่ทำให้มันสนุกด้วย สิ่งหนึ่งที่เรายังไม่ได้พูดถึง
มากนักคือ computational complexity theory หนึ่งในเหตุผลคือมันอาจน่ากลัวสักหน่อย และใช่แล้ว
complexity theory คือสาขาวิทยาศาสตร์คอมพิวเตอร์ที่มุ่ง classify ปัญหาการคำนวณ
ตามความยาก มี complexity class มากมายใน classical computing แต่ที่
พื้นฐานที่สุดคือ P problem เหล่านี้คือปัญหาที่แก้ได้ใน polynomial time ตามที่ scale ของ
ปัญหาเพิ่มขึ้น หมายความว่ามันง่ายต่อการแก้ ประเภทที่ยากกว่าถัดไปคือ NP problem ซึ่ง
ย่อมาจาก non-deterministic polynomial สิ่งเหล่านี้คือปัญหาที่คำตอบสามารถยืนยันได้ใน polynomial time แต่
ไม่จำเป็นต้องแก้ได้ ถัดไปคือ NP-complete และตอนนี้เราเข้าสู่ปัญหาที่ท้าทายจริง ๆ ที่ไม่มี
polynomial solution ที่รู้จัก นี่คือที่ที่ปัญหาโด่งดัง เช่น traveling salesman problem และแม้แต่เกม
Sudoku อาศัย ตอนนี้เมื่อ Quantum Computing เกิดขึ้น อย่างน้อยในทางทฤษฎี ผู้คนใช้ความพยายามมากในการ
หาว่าคอมพิวเตอร์ประเภทใหม่เหล่านี้จะแก้ปัญหา class ใดได้อย่างมีประสิทธิภาพ class ใหม่ของ
ปัญหาถูกประดิษฐ์ขึ้น เรียกว่า bounded error quantum polynomial หรือ BQP สำหรับนิยามที่เข้มงวดมัน
ยาวนิดหน่อย แต่มันคือ class ของ decision problem ที่แก้ได้โดยคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมใน polynomial time ด้วย
โอกาส error เล็กน้อย มีโอกาส error เพราะ quantum measurement สุ่มโดยธรรมชาติ แต่
ความน่าจะเป็น error สามารถน้อยได้ตามต้องการ ตอนนี้ class ทั้งหมดเหล่านี้อยู่ใน class ใหญ่กว่าที่เราเรียกว่า PSPACE และนี่คือที่
เราคิดว่า BQP อยู่ relative ต่อปัญหาประเภทอื่น แต่ยากมากที่จะพิสูจน์สิ่งนี้
ทางคณิตศาสตร์ คุณจะสังเกตว่า BQP quantum problem ไม่จำเป็นต้อง overlap กับ NP-complete problem
อย่างไรก็ตาม คุณยังอาจเห็น approach Quantum Computing บางอย่างที่มุ่งแก้ NP-complete problem ทำไม?
misconception ทั่วไปอย่างหนึ่งคือไม่มีประโยชน์ในการสำรวจ solution
ต่อปัญหาเช่น traveling salesman และ NP-complete อื่น ๆ สำหรับคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม หรือปัญหาใดก็ตามที่
mathematical proof สำหรับ quantum speedup ยังไม่ถูกหา อย่างไรก็ตาม นั่นไม่จำเป็นต้องเป็นกรณีนั้น
การหา mathematical proof ว่า quantum algorithm เร็วกว่า classical counterpart นั้นพบได้น้อย Shor และ
Grover เป็นสองในตัวอย่างไม่กี่อย่างที่ทำได้จนถึงตอนนี้ แต่นั่นก็โอเค จริง ๆ แม้แต่นัก
วิทยาศาสตร์คอมพิวเตอร์ยังพิสูจน์ไม่ได้ว่า class ของ P และ NP แตกต่างกัน แม้ intuition ทั้งหมดบอก
ว่าต้องเป็นเช่นนั้น นอกจากนี้การเปรียบเทียบ algorithm สองตัวและวิธี scale มักดู worst case
scenario ของแต่ละตัว เป็นไปได้มากว่าในทางปฏิบัติ worst case scenario ไม่ใช่สิ่งที่เราพบในชีวิตจริง ดังนั้น
เราไม่หมดหวัง แทนที่เราแนะนำ concept ของ heuristic solution ถ้าคุณเป็น
นักทดลอง คุณรู้จักและชอบ solution ประเภทนี้อยู่แล้ว heuristic คือ approach ใด ๆ ในการแก้
ปัญหาที่ pragmatic แต่ไม่จำเป็นต้อง optimal และนั่นดีมาก เพราะ solution ไม่จำเป็นต้อง
optimal เพื่อมีประโยชน์มากได้ ตัวอย่างเช่น นึกถึงแอปพลิเคชันทางการเงิน เรายังไม่พบ
exponential speedup สำหรับ financial algorithm ส่วนใหญ่ที่ quantum สามารถใช้ได้ แต่นั่นไม่จำเป็นต้องสำคัญ เราไม่ต้องการ optimal solution
ในการเงินอย่างน้อย เพราะ solution ที่มีประสิทธิภาพแค่ 1% มากขึ้นสามารถเท่ากับ billions ของดอลลาร์
ของกำไรได้ แล้วเรารู้ได้อย่างไรว่า use case และปัญหาใดเหมาะสำหรับ Quantum Computing ตอนนี้ และโดยนั้น
ฉันหมายถึงมีเหตุผลสำคัญที่เชื่อว่า quantum utility หรือแม้แต่ advantage สามารถพบได้ตอนนี้หรือ
ในอนาคตอันใกล้ บางทีง่ายกว่าที่จะตั้งชื่อสิ่งที่ปัญหาแน่นอนไม่ควรมีก่อน มัน
ต้องการ qubit จำนวนมากไม่ได้ เรายังไม่มีโปรเซสเซอร์ที่มี qubit หลักพันถึงหลักล้านให้ใช้ นั่นคือหนึ่งในเหตุผลหลัก
ที่ Shor's algorithm และอื่น ๆ ยังอยู่ไกลมาก circuit ก็ต้องไม่ลึกเหลือเชื่อ ยากสำหรับฉัน
ที่จะบอกว่า circuit depth เท่าไหร่จะไม่ work เพราะมันขึ้นอยู่กับ factor มากมาย แต่โดยทั่วไปถ้า
การทดลองของคุณต้องการ depth ที่คุณไม่เคยเห็นในวรรณกรรม คุณอาจเจอเวลาที่ยาก และ
สุดท้าย algorithm ประเภทใดก็ตามที่เรารู้ว่าต้องการ error correction ยังทำไม่ได้ สิ่งที่ควรมองหาอย่างไรก็ตามคือการทดลองที่ใช้
qubit ส่วนใหญ่ที่มีบน QPU ใด ๆ เราเน้นย้ำด้วยความสำคัญของ error mitigation และ suppression
และสุดท้ายควรมี extension ที่ชัดเจนไปยัง future
application ที่สำคัญสำหรับสังคมและที่เราอาจเห็นในที่สุดนำไปสู่ Quantum
Advantage ตอนนี้มาพูดถึงตัวอย่าง use case ที่อยู่ใน 3 หมวดหลักที่เรา
ระบุว่าน่าจะเห็นผลลัพธ์ที่ดีในระยะสั้นถึงกลาง
พื้นที่แรกคือการจำลองธรรมชาติ เราพูดถึงสิ่งนี้มาก่อนแล้ว มีโอกาสมากมายให้คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม
ปรับปรุงการวิจัยที่ทำในระดับโมเลกุลและอะตอม
และเหตุผลสำหรับสิ่งนี้คือวิธี classical ปัจจุบันถูกจำกัดด้วยคำอธิบายทาง mathematicก ที่ไม่มีประสิทธิภาพโดยพื้นฐานของ
โครงสร้างอะตอม การเก็บและจัดการ quantum state ต้องใช้ resource แบบ exponential
บนคอมพิวเตอร์แบบคลาสสิก แต่ทำได้อย่างมีประสิทธิภาพบนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม และนั่นทำให้การจำลอง material
และ chemical modeling เป็นหนึ่งในพื้นที่แอปพลิเคชันที่มีแนวโน้มมากที่สุด โดยเฉพาะกว่านั้น อาจนำไปสู่
การพัฒนาใน carbon dioxide sequestration แบตเตอรี่ทางเลือก หรือการประดิษฐ์ยาใหม่ algorithm
บางอย่างที่เกี่ยวข้องโดยเฉพาะในพื้นที่นี้คือ variational quantum eigensolver VQE ซึ่งใช้ estimate
คุณสมบัติบางอย่างของ material เช่น equilibrium หรือ minimum energy state อีกตัวอย่างคือ
Time Dynamics Simulation TDS algorithm นั้นใช้ estimate response function หรือ spectral property ของ
material และฉันยังอยากพูดถึง newcomer อย่าง sample-based quantum diagonalization ซึ่งเราคิดว่าจะได้ยินเรื่อง
มันมากขึ้นในอนาคตอันใกล้ พื้นที่แอปพลิเคชันถัดไปคือ optimization ตอนนี้ optimization ค่อนข้าง
แพร่หลายใน computing อย่างที่จินตนาการได้ ดังนั้น use case ค่อนข้างมากมายและหลากหลาย
อย่างไรก็ตาม ตัวอย่างบางอย่างที่ได้ยินบ่อยคือ portfolio optimization ในการเงิน industrial design และยัง
distribution และ supply chain algorithm ที่พบบ่อยที่สุดที่คุณน่าจะได้ยินเกี่ยวกับ optimization คือ algorithm ที่เราได้
ครอบคลุมในเชิงลึกแล้ว นั่นคือ quantum approximate optimization algorithm หรือ
QAOA สุดท้าย พื้นที่หนึ่งที่มีความตื่นเต้นมากในช่วงไม่กี่ปีที่ผ่านมาคือ quantum machine learning ตอนนี้
ฉันคิดว่ายุติธรรมที่จะพูดว่า QML ดูไม่เหมือนจะเกิดขึ้นเร็วเท่า simulation ในความน่าจะเป็น แต่ถึงกระนั้น มี
algorithm ที่น่าประทับใจที่คนทำอย่างสม่ำเสมอซึ่งสอดคล้องกับ use case สำคัญมาก
บาง use case ที่เป็นไปได้เหล่านี้คือ natural language processing, network traffic analysis และแม้แต่ fraud
detection ในธุรกรรมทางการเงิน algorithm ที่เกี่ยวข้องในพื้นที่นี้คือ quantum support vector
machine, quantum neural network และ quantum generative adversarial network ตอนนี้เพื่อชี้แจง สามกลุ่ม
ที่เพิ่งอธิบายเป็น application area กว้าง ๆ มีประโยชน์ด้วยที่สังเกตว่าในชุมชนมี
ประโยชน์สำหรับกลุ่มที่ทำงานร่วมกันที่โฟกัสที่หัวข้อเฉพาะ IBM นำ initiative ไม่นานมานี้
เรียกว่า Working Groups เพื่อช่วย collaborator พบปะและสร้าง synergy ที่มีประโยชน์ใน 4 พื้นที่เฉพาะ
ได้แก่ Healthcare and life science, Materials and HPC, High energy physics และ
Optimization นี่คือกลุ่มปัจจุบันของเราและ entity ที่เกี่ยวข้องในความพยายามเหล่านั้น ถ้าอยากได้ยินเพิ่มเติมว่า
working group ทำอะไร เราแนบ white paper สี่ฉบับในคำอธิบายด้านล่าง ตอนนี้อย่างที่บอก
ฉันคิดว่าสิ่งที่ดีที่สุดในจุดนี้ของคอร์สคือการใช้เวลาสำรวจว่าคนกำลังทำงานกับปัญหาประเภทใดบน
Cutting Edge ของเทคโนโลยีนี้ และพัฒนา intuition ของเราในการรู้ว่า algorithm ประเภทใดจะ work และ
วิธี apply มัน และก่อนเริ่ม ฉันแค่อยากชี้แจงให้ชัดว่าเป้าหมายหลักที่นี่ไม่ใช่การเข้าใจทุก
รายละเอียดของการทดลอง การวิเคราะห์ประเภทนี้อาจน่ากลัวมากแม้แต่สำหรับผู้เชี่ยวชาญถ้างานวิจัยอยู่นอก
expertise ของคุณเล็กน้อย เป้าหมายเพียงเพื่อช่วยพัฒนา intuition สำหรับประเภทของปัญหาที่คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม
ทำได้ดี และวิธีจัดการพวกมัน และถ้าสนใจรายละเอียดเพิ่มเติมและสิ่งนี้จุดประกาย
idea ของตัวเอง ฉันแน่นอนแนะนำให้ไปอ่านงานวิจัยฉบับเต็มด้วยตัวเอง use case เฉพาะและ
งานวิจัยที่เราจะดูอย่างลึกมีดังนี้ อย่างแรกเราจะสำรวจงานวิจัยที่พูดถึง
simulation ของ hadron dynamics นี่อยู่ใน high energy physics category ถัดไปเราจะดูปัญหา optimization
โดยเฉพาะ biased field counter-adiabatic quantum optimization และสุดท้ายเราจะดูอีก
simulation problem แต่ครั้งนี้โฟกัสที่ mRNA ซึ่งเป็นโมเลกุลสำคัญสำหรับ
การพัฒนายาและ therapeutic ถ้าคุ้นเคยหรือไม่คุ้นเคยกับงานวิจัยเหล่านี้ ไม่เป็นไร เราจะ
ดูทั้งสามเป็นงานวิจัยสำคัญที่จัดการปัญหาขนาดใหญ่และแสดงวิธีที่คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม
เริ่มถูกใช้เป็นวิธีการวิจัยทางวิทยาศาสตร์อีกวิธี อย่างแรกคือการจำลอง hadron
dynamics และเราจะเจาะลึกงานวิจัยของกลุ่ม Martin Savage ที่ University of Washington ชื่อว่า Quantum
Simulations of Hadron Dynamics in the Schwinger Model Using 112
Qubits ถ้าคุณไม่ใช่นักฟิสิกส์พลังงานสูง คุณยังอาจคุ้นเคยกับคำว่า hadron เช่นใน
Large Hadron Collider หรือ LHC ซึ่งเป็นเครื่องเร่งอนุภาคขนาดยักษ์ 27 กิโลเมตรในเส้นรอบวงที่ทำให้
เป็นไปได้ที่จะสังเกต Higgs boson ในที่สุด hadron คืออนุภาคประกอบย่อยอะตอมที่ทำจาก
อนุภาคเล็กกว่าที่เรียกว่า quark ตัวอย่างบางอย่างคือ neutron และ proton สำหรับบริบทเล็กน้อย LHC ถูกสร้าง
เพื่อศึกษา fundamental physics และสิ่งที่เกิดขึ้นกับอนุภาคเมื่อพวกมันชนกันที่พลังงานสูงมาก
ในท่อวงกลมนี้ โดยทำสิ่งนี้ นักวิทยาศาสตร์หวังที่จะเรียนรู้เพิ่มเติมว่า early Universe เกิดขึ้นมา
ได้อย่างไร และอย่างที่พูดถึงก่อน มันยังใช้หา boson ซึ่งเป็นอนุภาคที่ยากจับ ที่รับผิดชอบมวล
ของ fundamental particle ตอนนี้ในทางทฤษฎี interaction ของอนุภาคเหล่านี้สามารถ
จำลองตั้งแต่ต้นจนจบด้วยคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมที่ทรงพลังเพียงพอ เรายังไม่ถึงตรงนั้น แต่ progress
กำลังถูกสร้าง Schwinger model เป็น simple model ที่ใช้จำลอง dynamics บางส่วนเหล่านี้และกลายเป็นหนึ่งใน
model ที่ได้รับความนิยมมากที่สุด รายละเอียดของ model ไม่สำคัญมากตอนนี้ แต่สำหรับผู้ที่
อยากรู้ มันเป็น model ที่อธิบายพฤติกรรมของ electron และ positron ที่ interact ผ่าน photon ใน 1+1 D
dimension หมายถึงมี spatial dimension หนึ่งและเวลา model นี้มีความคล้ายคลึงกับ Quantum
chromodynamics มากซึ่งอธิบายวิธี quark และ hadron interact ซึ่งยากมากที่จะจำลอง ดังนั้น
Schwinger model มักใช้เป็น toy model เพื่อ investigate ปรากฏการณ์บางอย่างที่เหมือนกันกับ
ทั้งคู่ ตอนนี้วิธีที่เราจะดำเนินกับตัวอย่างนี้และตัวอย่างที่เหลือที่ฉันเลือกที่นี่ด้วยคือ
การถามตัวเองด้วยชุดคำถาม อย่างแรกคือทำไมเราจึงมีเหตุผลที่เชื่อว่าการจำลองสิ่งนี้
บนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมจะ work ได้เลย? ในกรณีนี้ electron และ positron ใน Schwinger model มี screening
effect ที่ทำให้ correlation ระหว่าง fermion ที่อยู่ห่างกัน decay แบบ exponential ตาม separation และนี่หมายความว่า
ไม่มี long-range interaction มากนักจาก qubit ด้านหนึ่งของชิปไปอีกด้านหนึ่ง
ซึ่งเรารู้ว่าเกิด error ง่ายมาก ดังนั้นนี่ดีมากสำหรับ hardware ที่มีตอนนี้ ถัดไปคือ
หัวข้อนี้น่าสนใจจริง ๆ ไหม? ฉันหวังว่าฉันโน้มน้าวคุณแล้วว่าใช่ high energy physics สำคัญมาก
ผู้คนยินดีใช้เงินหลาย billion สร้าง LHC และนักวิทยาศาสตร์และช่างเทคนิค
หลายพันคนทั่วโลกอุทิศชีวิตให้กับสาขานี้ มันสำคัญขนาดนั้น แต่
Schwinger model เป็น simplistic และไม่ได้ออกแบบมาครอบคลุม 3 spatial dimension อย่างไรก็ตาม มันเป็น
model สำคัญเพราะยังให้ slice ที่ testable ในปัจจุบันและ simplification ที่มีประโยชน์ของ
ทฤษฎีเต็มรูปแบบ สุดท้าย งานนี้ทำอย่างไร หรือ approach ใดที่จะใช้ถ้ากำลังดำเนิน
การทดลองประเภท simulation ต่อ VQE เป็นหนึ่งใน approach ที่พบบ่อยที่สุดและขั้นตอนแรกมักเหมือนกันเสมอ
เตรียม ground state ในกรณีนี้คือ vacuum state และในการทดลองนี้พวกเขาใช้ VQE version ใหม่ที่เรียกว่า SC-
ADAPT VQE เพื่อเตรียมทั้ง ground state และ hadron wave packet บน vacuum ขั้นตอนถัดไปคือ
ให้ hadron evolve หรือ propagate ตามเวลา สุดท้ายต้องระบุ
observable ที่ต้องการ detect ถ้าขั้นตอนเหล่านั้นฟังดูคุ้นเคยสักนิด ลบส่วน Hadron wave
packet ออก นั่นเพราะขั้นตอนเหล่านี้คล้ายมากกับสิ่งที่เราครอบคลุมในตัวอย่าง QAOA ในตอนก่อน
หวังว่าคุณเริ่มเห็น pattern บางอย่างที่เกิดขึ้น component ที่ต้องการสำหรับ VQE คล้ายมากกับ QAOA
เราเริ่มใน familiar state คือ vacuum state แล้วให้มัน evolve ตามเวลาด้วยชุด exponentiated
Hamiltonian แบ่งเป็น chunk ที่จัดการได้ ที่ n คือจำนวน division ความแตกต่างใหญ่เพียงอย่างเดียวที่นี่
คือเราสร้าง wave packet ของ hadron ที่ center อยู่ใน circuit ของเรา ก่อนที่จะให้มัน evolve แล้ว
ทำสิ่งนี้ได้อย่างไร? vacuum state คือ ground state และเราได้ cover วิธี map สิ่งนี้แล้วในระดับหนึ่ง ตอนนี้การเตรียม hadron
wave packet แตกต่างออกไปเล็กน้อย บน vacuum นี้ hadron สามารถถูก excite โดยการสร้าง fermion-antifermion pair บน
adjacent site โดยเตรียม superposition ของ hadron ดังกล่าวที่ตำแหน่งต่าง ๆ wave
packet arbitrary สามารถเตรียมได้ ผู้เขียน center wave packet ของพวกเขาตรงกลาง circuit เพื่อสังเกต evolution
โดยไม่เกิน boundary แต่จำไว้ว่าชื่อของเกมเมื่อทำงานกับ noisy QPU คือการรักษา
circuit depth ให้จัดการได้ เพื่อทำสิ่งนี้ SC-ADAPT VQE protocol ใช้ symmetry และ
hierarchy ใน length scale เพื่อกำหนด low-depth quantum circuit สำหรับ state preparation ไอเดียคือสิ่งนี้
จะสร้าง ansatz ที่มี parameter จำนวนน้อยลง เท่ากับ depth ที่ตื้นกว่า รายละเอียดเพิ่มเติม
สามารถหาได้ในงานวิจัยมากกว่าที่เรามีเวลา ดังนั้นตรวจสอบให้แน่ใจว่าดูมัน ตอนนี้มาดูผลลัพธ์ การทดลองนี้รันบน
IBM Quantum Heron device และ implement เทคนิค error mitigation และ suppression หลายอย่าง
รวมถึงเทคนิคใหม่กว่าที่เรียกว่า operator decoherence renormalization รวมถึง dynamical decoupling, zero noise
extrapolation และ Pauli twirling ตอนนี้มาลองตีความข้อมูล observable ที่เราจะวัดจริง ๆ
เพื่อสังเกตวิธีที่ wave packet propagate คือสิ่งที่เรียกว่า chiral condensate ซึ่งเป็นนิดหน่อย
abstract แต่โดยพื้นฐานคือ superfluid phase ของ hadron ตอนนี้เราเห็น wave packet center อยู่ที่นี่บน
site ที่ถูกกำหนดเพื่อรันการทดลองนี้ ที่สีสอดคล้องกับ chiral condensate
ด้านซ้ายแสดงผลลัพธ์ที่ไม่มี error จาก simulator ในขณะที่ด้านขวาแสดงผลลัพธ์จาก IBM quantum
computer Torino ในอุดมคติสิ่งเหล่านี้จะเป็น mirror image ซึ่งกันและกันเนื่องจาก symmetry ดังนั้นคุณเห็นว่ามี
ความไม่สมบูรณ์บ้าง ตอนนี้ Y-axis แนวตั้งนี้สอดคล้องกับ chunk ของเวลาที่ฉัน
วัดก่อนหน้า ดังนั้นทำไมไม่ตัดแนวนอนผ่าน time step แรกและสุดท้ายของข้อมูลเพื่อดู
ว่าเกิดอะไรกับ wave packet ที่เวลา t = 1 ที่นี่ใน orange สอดคล้องกับ
cut นี้ คุณเห็นว่า chiral condensate แคบและ localize มันยังสอดคล้องได้ดีมากกับ
simulation ที่ทำเพื่อเปรียบเทียบ ที่ t = 14 อย่างไรก็ตาม มัน spread มากขึ้นและ localize น้อย
ลง บางทีการเปรียบเทียบกับ simulator อาจไม่ perfect อย่างนั้น แต่คุณยังเห็น agreement ที่ดีมาก
ระหว่าง theory และข้อมูลซึ่งน่าให้กำลังใจ โดยสรุป นี่เป็นตัวอย่างที่ cool มากของงาน simulation ประเภทที่
คุณอาจไม่นึกถึงในตอนแรกว่าจะ apply คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมกับมัน อย่างไรก็ตามจริง ๆ คุณทำได้และมัน work
ไม่ perfect แต่คุณไม่ต้องเป็น particle physics expert เพื่อเห็นว่าคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม predict outward propagation
ของ wave packet อย่างแม่นยำ ซึ่งเป็นสิ่งที่เราคาดว่าจะพบ หวังว่างานในอนาคตในพื้นที่นี้จะดำเนิน
ต่อและนักฟิสิกส์พลังงานสูงจะหาวิธี incorporate Quantum Computing เข้า work stream ของพวกเขา เป้าหมายคือ
แก้ปัญหาเชิงทฤษฎีอย่างแม่นยำมากขึ้นและสิ่งที่ทำ classically ไม่ได้ และใช้การทดลองเพื่อยอมรับหรือปฏิเสธ theory
ด้วยความหวังที่จะค้นพบ physics ใหม่ สร้าง detector ที่ดีขึ้น และนำไปสู่ความเข้าใจที่ดีขึ้นของธรรมชาติในระดับพื้นฐาน
ที่สุด ตัวอย่างถัดไปโฟกัสที่ optimization และจะเป็นการ deep dive เข้าสู่งานวิจัยชื่อ biased field
digitized counter-adiabatic quantum optimization ซึ่งทำโดยสมาชิกของทีม KIPU Quantum ที่
University of the Basque Country ในสเปน เราจะเริ่มเหมือนเดิม
ด้วยชุดนิยาม อย่างแรกคือ counter-adiabatic ซึ่งเป็นประเภทของ evolution ที่ suppress non-adiabatic
effect ที่ระบบพบโดยไม่คำนึงว่ากระบวนการเหล่านั้นเร็วแค่ไหน ลองนึกถึง adiabatic theorem จาก
ตอนก่อน โดยปกติต้องให้ระบบ evolve ช้ามาก ถ้าต้องการให้มันอยู่ใน ground state
นี่เป็นปัญหาใหญ่เพราะยิ่งต้องให้สิ่งต่าง ๆ evolve ช้าลง เรายิ่งมีเวลามากขึ้นสำหรับ error ที่จะ
เกิดขึ้น Counter-adiabatic driving มักย่อว่า CD มุ่งต่อสู้สิ่งนี้โดย
เพิ่ม term ที่ counteract excitation ที่ไม่ต้องการเหล่านี้ ไอเดียหลักที่นี่คือ speed up การทดลองทั้งหมดและ
ลด quantum circuit depth โดย suppress excitation ที่อาจนำไปสู่ spurious
transition ตอนนี้มาพูดถึงว่า bias field คืออะไร iterative algorithm อื่น ๆ เช่น VQE รับ classical parameter ลงใน
state เหล่านี้และใช้ classical optimizer ค้นหา parameter space หลายมิติเพื่อหาชุด
ที่ให้ minimum expectation value สำหรับ Hamiltonian ที่ fixed แต่ในกรณีนี้พวกเขาแทนที่จะแปรผัน Hamiltonian แต่ละ
ครั้ง เคลื่อนแบบ adiabatic จาก case ที่รู้จักไปยัง case ที่สนใจ แต่เนื่องจากไม่มี classical parameter ที่
ส่งและไม่มี variational wave function คุณจะ update state ของคุณจาก pass หนึ่งที่ Hamiltonian ไปยังถัดไปได้
อย่างไร? พวกเขาเพิ่ม bias field ให้ Hamiltonian ไม่ว่าจะเป็น lowest energy state จาก run ก่อน
ก็เพิ่ม term ใน Hamiltonian เพื่อ bias state ในทิศทางนั้น แล้วทำไมการทดลองนี้จึง
น่าสนใจ? อย่างแรกนี่เป็น approach ใหม่ที่สามารถ apply กับปัญหา optimization อื่น ๆ ได้ทั่วไปมากขึ้น
แต่ในกรณีนี้พวกเขา apply กับ Ising spin glass problem อย่างที่พูดถึงก่อน optimization
combinatorial หลายอย่างสามารถ reformulate เป็นการแก้หา low energy state ของ Ising Hamiltonian
Ising model คือชุด microscopic spin ที่กระจายบน array model สามารถใช้อธิบาย spin glass ซึ่ง
magnetization ไม่เป็นระเบียบ โดยพื้นฐาน magnetic moment เล็ก ๆ ถูก orient แบบสุ่มใน array และ
ทำไมเราถึงคิดว่านี่จะ work? เราได้ cover แล้วว่าเรากำลังต่อสู้กับ issue สองอย่างทั่วไปที่พบใน
variational algorithm เมื่อเราครอบคลุมนิยามของงานวิจัย แต่เพื่อสรุป algorithm ที่พวกเขา
propose speeds up evolution เพื่อลด circuit depth ในขณะที่ยัง suppress non-adiabatic transition
นอกจากนี้มันไม่พึ่งพา classical optimization routine ใด ๆ ซึ่งอาจเป็น issue ที่นำไปสู่ Barren
plateau และติดอยู่ที่ local minima สุดท้าย ผู้เขียนยังแน่ใจว่า align interaction ในปัญหา
Hamiltonian กับ hardware connectivity ของ real QPU ซึ่งสำคัญเสมอ สุดท้าย สิ่งนี้ work อย่างไร
อย่างที่พูด ไม่มี classical optimizer ที่ใช้ที่นี่เหมือนที่มักใช้ใน iterative quantum algorithm
แทนที่โดยการป้อน solution จาก iteration แต่ละตัวเป็น input สำหรับถัดไป biased field digitized
quantum optimization algorithm ปรับแต่ง ground state อย่างค่อยเป็นค่อยไป ทำให้ใกล้กับ
final evolved state มากขึ้นเรื่อย ๆ และรวมกับ counter-adiabatic protocol เราทำสิ่งนี้ได้แม้กับ short depth quantum
circuit ที่ควรรันอย่างราบรื่นบน noisy hardware ดังนั้นเมื่อการทดลองถูกทำ ผู้เขียนเลือกรัน
algorithm บน 127 qubit IBM quantum computer Brisbane ที่นี่ผู้เขียนแสดง
energization ของ optimization algorithm สำหรับ nearest-neighbor randomly generated spin glass instance
ที่ qubit มากกว่า 100 พวกเขาเปรียบเทียบผลลัพธ์การจำลอง ideal จาก DCQ และ BF-DCQ
รวมถึงผลลัพธ์การทดลอง และยังแสดงผลลัพธ์จาก classical solver ที่เรียกว่า Gurobi เป็น reference ตอนนี้
ด้วยแค่ 10 iteration BF-DCQ ให้ enhancement ที่ drastic เมื่อเปรียบเทียบกับ
DCQ แม้ผลลัพธ์การทดลองจะแตกต่างจาก ideal result เล็กน้อยเนื่องจาก noise แต่ performance ยัง
ดีกว่า ideal DCQ นี่แสดงว่ายังมี progress ที่ยอดเยี่ยมมากกำลังเกิดขึ้นเกี่ยวกับ
Quantum optimization และผลลัพธ์ที่ดีกำลังถูกรายงานสำหรับ qubit มากกว่า 100 ตัวเป็นครั้งแรก
สุดท้ายแต่สำคัญคือมีงานวิจัยที่น่าสนใจมากที่สำรวจ mRNA structure prediction จากเพื่อน ๆ ที่
Moderna Pharmaceuticals และชื่อว่า "mRNA Secondary Structure Prediction Using Utility-Scale Quantum
Computers" เพื่อเริ่มต้น ถ้าคุณเหมือนฉันยังไม่ได้เรียน biology มาหลายปีแล้ว คุณสามารถทบทวนตัวเองว่า
mRNA คืออะไร Messenger RNA คือประเภทของ RNA ที่เกี่ยวข้องกับการสังเคราะห์โปรตีน มัน
โดยพื้นฐานอ่านคำสั่งที่ให้โดย DNA secondary structure ของ mRNA คือวิธีที่ chain fold ไม่มากก็น้อย และ
ปัญหา RNA secondary structure prediction คือการหา folding ที่ stable ที่สุดของ sequence
ของ base ของ nucleotide ที่สร้าง DNA และ RNA ซึ่งก็คือ C, G, U และ A สิ่งนี้
รูปที่นี่แสดง folding structure ทั่วไปบางอย่างที่พบใน mRNA แต่ละสีที่ highlight ที่นี่แสดง
secondary structure ต่างกัน แต่ลักษณะเฉพาะที่แน่นอนว่าอะไรทำให้ structure หนึ่งดีกว่าอีก
อย่างหนึ่งยังไม่เป็นที่เข้าใจดี สิ่งที่เราทำได้คือหาว่า structure ไหนมี free energy ต่ำสุดเมื่อเปรียบเทียบกับ
unfolded state และนั่นคือที่คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมเข้ามา ดังนั้นทำไม mRNA secondary structure
จึงสำคัญ? การ predict มันอย่างแม่นยำจริง ๆ สำคัญไม่เพียงแต่สำหรับเข้าใจ DNA และ gene ของเรา แต่ยัง
สำหรับการออกแบบ RNA-based therapeutic เช่น วัคซีน covid-19 มีเหตุผลที่เชื่อว่า approach ใน
งานวิจัยนี้จะ work เพราะนี่เป็นที่รู้จักมานานว่าเป็น optimization problem ที่ยากมากสำหรับคอมพิวเตอร์แบบคลาสสิก
เนื่องจาก configuration ที่เป็นไปได้มีจำนวนมาก และสำหรับบาง configuration มันจริง ๆ เป็น
NP-complete problem อย่างไรก็ตาม บนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม เราสามารถ formulate secondary structure prediction เป็น
binary optimization problem ซึ่งเป็นสิ่งที่เรารู้วิธีจัดการ นอกจากนี้มีหลักฐานในวรรณกรรมแล้ว
ของการ predict RNA อย่างแม่นยำบน quantum device ขนาดเล็กและ quantum simulator ดังนั้น คำถามที่ชัดเจนคือ
นี่จะ work บน hardware ขนาดใหญ่ไหม? การทดลองทำโดยใช้สิ่งที่เรียกว่า conditional value
at risk variational quantum eigensolver ซึ่งเป็นการดัดแปลง VQE algorithm แบบดั้งเดิมและ
คาดว่าจะ converge ได้ดีขึ้น กราฟนี้แสดง distribution ของ measurement
probability ของ sample bit string พร้อม energy ที่สอดคล้องสำหรับ 42
nucleotide 80 qubit instance ที่นี่ bit string symbolize การจับคู่ของ
nucleotide มัน illustrate ว่า lowest energy bit string มี energy value ของ -140 ซึ่งตรงกับ lowest
energy bit string ที่พบโดย classical solver เปรียบเทียบ ดังนั้นนั่นดีและนี่คือ optimal folded
structure ของ nucleotide chain นั้น ตาม lowest energy bit string ที่ hardware
หาได้ และด้วยนั้นเราถึงบทสรุปของตอนนี้แล้ว ตอนนี้เป้าหมายของฉันที่นี่ไม่ใช่การ overwhelm คุณด้วย
รายละเอียดจากงานวิจัยต่าง ๆ อย่างที่พูด ฉันแค่อยากให้คุณมีบริบทเพียงพอเพื่อเข้าใจว่า
งาน Cutting Edge ในสาขามีลักษณะอย่างไรตอนนี้ หวังว่านี่จะทำให้ gear บางตัวหมุน
ในทุกคนและโดยการเห็นวิธีที่คนอื่นเข้าถึงปัญหา คุณจะสามารถเชื่อมต่อและมี
ความมั่นใจที่จะลองการทดลองควอนตัมใหม่ ๆ ที่คุณอาจไม่ทำมาก่อน และเฮ้ บางทีบางอย่างเหล่านั้นอาจ
ไม่ pan out และนั่นก็โอเค นั่นคือเหตุผลที่นี่คือการวิจัย ก้าวต่อไปจำไว้ว่าประเภทของปัญหาที่เรา
สนใจสามารถจัดกลุ่มได้ทั้งตาม methodology หรือตาม subject และเราได้วาง outline ว่าสิ่งที่เราเชื่อว่า
มีแนวโน้มมากที่สุดในระยะสั้น จำไว้ว่า Quantum Computing ไม่ได้ดีสำหรับทุกอย่าง และจริง ๆ นี่เป็นแค่
การยืนยันว่าเราเก่งแค่ไหนใน classical computing แค่เพราะคุณคิดว่าสามารถ apply Quantum Computing
กับปัญหา ไม่ได้หมายความว่ามันจะให้ผลลัพธ์ที่น่าสนใจ น่าเสียดาย คุณต้องพิจารณา scaling circuit
depth เป็นดาบสองคม เราต้องการให้มันใหญ่พอควรเพื่อทำงานที่น่าสนใจที่คอมพิวเตอร์แบบคลาสสิก
ทำไม่ได้ แต่ตอนนี้เนื่องจาก hardware noise เราไม่สามารถ push มันให้ใหญ่มาก เพราะ fidelity จะ
ลดลง มันเกี่ยวกับการหา sweet spot และรู้ว่ามันเป็น moving target ดังนั้นใช้เวลา
ระหว่างนี้กับตอนถัดไปคิดอย่างจริงจังเกี่ยวกับปัญหาบางอย่างที่คุณเจอมาและวิธีที่คุณอาจต้องการ approach
มันด้วยสิ่งที่เราเรียนรู้มาจนถึงจุดนี้ ลองคิดสร้างสรรค์ อย่าจำกัดตัวเอง และถ้ามี idea แม้ว่าคุณคิดว่า
บ้าไปหน่อย แจ้งให้ฉันรู้ใน comment ด้านล่าง ขอบคุณที่ดู และเจอกันครั้งหน้า